it's no secret that Netflix is a big
spender in 2017 alone the streaming
service dropped six point three billion
dollars on original and acquired
programming demolishing the video
content budgets of Viacom Amazon CBS
Apple and Facebook but the lion's share
of Netflix is budget of course goes to
original programming and to do that the
company has signed off on some seriously
extravagant series but which of the most
expensive shows Netflix has ever
produced
we've got your numbers Hemlock Grove
American creature killer series Hemlock
Grove was supposed to be a surefire hit
for Netflix but it ended up being little
more than an average show with a hefty
price tag is there something you want to
tell me I'm about to do things I don't
want to sooner or later I'm gonna have
to give in when it premiered in 2013
Hemlock Grove ranked among Netflix's
most expensive shows to date reportedly
costing 40 million dollars for season
ones 13 episodes far more than most
major television networks are willing to
shell out for even a 22 episode run
entire bloodlines are both become
extinct the series received a less than
stellar critical reception though it did
manage to garner a dedicated fanbase
which ultimately kept the show alive for
two additional seasons before Netflix
pulled the plug orange is the new black
as one of Netflix is most well known and
widely acclaimed series it's not
surprising that orange is the new black
ranks among the most expensive offerings
on the platform is it complicated ladies
in a complicated place according to
Peter Miceli former co head of TV at CAA
the show runs just under 4 million
dollars per episode
but investing in the screen rights to
Piper Kerman 'he's memoir of the same
name has paid massive dividends for
Netflix in Awards and worldwide brand
recognition
house of cards at the time of its
creation political thriller house of
cards set a new standard for Netflix for
quality as well as production costs
former star and executive producer Kevin
Spacey once said the production
reportedly spent 100 million dollars on
the first season alone we don't submit
to Tara we make the terror as the show
closes in on its sixth and final season
sans Spacey in late 2018 the series will
go down as a hit for the platform
Netflix reportedly up their subscriber
count by at least twenty seven point
five million when house of cards debuted
in 2013 with the ultra popular political
drama playing a major role in the
streaming service winning their fans
vote we're just getting started
Seinfeld's comedy Netflix isn't just
shelling out for high-profile original
series it's also forking it over for
original stand-up as well and no deal
was more expensive than the one they
made with Jerry Seinfeld would I have
been funny if I grew up in Peoria in a
whorehouse raised by prostitutes
absolutely but this is what I had to
work with Netflix reportedly paid
Seinfeld a staggering 100 million
dollars for a pair of stand-up specials
bundled with the streaming rights to his
hit web series comedians in cars getting
coffee but the platform was happy to pay
Seinfeld's lofty premium Netflix is
chief content officer Ted Saran dose
told deadlines jerry is known the world
over as both a great TV innovator and
beloved comic voice we are incredibly
proud to welcome him to the Netflix
comedy family excited
I'm looking forward to it the get-down
Baz Luhrmann and Stephen Adly gear
juices South Bronx musical drama to get
down caused a lot of tension between
Sony Pictures Television and Netflix
according to Variety that shows two and
a half year production sought to show
runners and a whole slew of riders come
and go allegedly due to Luhrmann's
involvement a money burning budget
coupled with a lack of actual filming
saw Sony get fed up quickly but Netflix
is Suren dose refused to greenlight
development until Lerman agreed to
direct the series from start to finish
boom from pain to slums we got cheese
that's what I'll be
my friends in me when the get downs 12
episode season finally wrapped
production reportedly ended up costing
at least 120 million dollars and
possibly more than 190 million dollars
all when making it one of the most
expensive shows in television history
but while it was cancelled after its
first season Netflix is VP of original
content Cyndi Holland told Variety we're
about supporting our artists and
supporting their vision working with Baz
that his team was one of the most
rewarding experiences of my life the
crown Netflix's historical drama the
crown tells the biographical story of
Queen Elizabeth the second and most
production costs that would make the
real royal family tighten their corsets
what do you want to degree no one wants
a college lecturers sovereign they want
a queen the show's first season alone
reportedly cost a record-setting 130
million dollars in 2016 although show
creator Peter Morgan thinks that
estimation is closer to the total cost
for the first two seasons that still
equates to a whopping six point five to
13 million dollars per hour long episode
helping drive up production costs was
the flawless recreation of Queen
Elizabeth's wedding dress which cost
approximately 37 thousand dollars we had
teams of six people working for six
weeks just embroidering the Train and
the dress bat and someone had to sign
off on a life-size replica of Buckingham
Palace altered carbon debuting in
February 2018 dystopian cyberpunk series
altered carbon is rumored to be one of
Netflix's most expensive shows
you've been provided with this body
which came equipped with military-grade
Urich em in combat muscle memory based
on the 2002 novel by Richard K Morgan
altered carbon remained in development
for nearly a decade and a half
originally optioned by Warner Brothers
the show began its expensive March to
Netflix's lineup once terminator genisys
screenwriter lisa kelly Greta's and game
of thrones director
Miguel Zapata Nick signed on the exact
cost of altered carbons production
remains a conservatively estimated 7
million dollars per episode
however Cal agreed has told thr that
number is really funny I feel
comfortable saying that that number is
not correct I would say it's inaccurate
regardless of how off the first season
seventy million dollar estimate may be
if this show gets its second season
it'll likely be breaking the bank as one
of Netflix's most expensive shows ever I
thought you'd be vehicle they made me
bring all this Beckham thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]